okay well first of all let me start by
saying uh i've seen all of season two it
is real good fans are gonna love it uh i
you know that's it i'll i mean have a
great day thank you so much
um
the thing is with a show like this you
really never know after the first season
what's gonna happen on season two did
you did you know early on like you're
definitely gonna be back for season two
uh no i didn't know yeah you know it's
the entertainment industry so
you never know what's gonna happen so no
i did not know that i was definitely
gonna be back but i did feel like daniel
uh had unfinished business uh in terms
of where we ended season one so i was
excited at the prospect of being back
for season two and really really really
excited and honored the way that um the
stories were reflected because you know
i feel like daniel does have a
substantial amount of um you know work
within this season uh he's the first
person to start talking about kovid um
daniel is a truth teller and he's very
vocal in his experience he talks about
uh systemic racism
and uh to talk about those things that
were such so impactful in our lives over
this past year and a half it was uh
really cool i felt honored and
privileged and
you know like i was doing something that
mattered 100 percent also i think the
audience
knows obviously more than the characters
about coveting what's coming and i can
see the audience as your character is
screaming about kovid and everyone's
ignoring it you know i can see the
audience beating like
do they not see what's coming
yeah they're like how can you not see
that coming they're like yeah because we
saw it come no we didn't know
um
one of the things though i always love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of a series and movies tv
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the actual making of the
morning show
uh surprise people to know about the
actual making of the morning show
um
i don't know like just that it's
um
you know that it's you know what it is
that
our cast and crew um
it's pretty like run-of-the-mill like we
have the people on our show like we're
all all the characters are going through
like all this drama in the workspace but
we are everyone pretty much has a family
and it's kind of like an uh in essence
for us a nine to five job and just like
we show up uh we we do work and uh
people are pretty like organized and um
work well together and then we go home
and uh and it's cool for me as an artist
because it's in in one sense it's a
dream job for me because i just
literally like get up i drive to the
studio i shoot the thing and then i come
back and uh that type of normality is
exciting for an artist when you know we
don't get it all the time most of the
time it's like i don't know where i'm
gonna go or what i'm gonna do and so
that sort of stability i think is it
might be surprising for people um who
watch the show
uh daniel at times uh can act a little
bit rash and he gets pretty upset about
certain things do you do you agree with
the level of like volume of his
upsetness or do you think it's sort of
like do you know what i'm saying about
this like because he goes to like a nine
when sometimes i think he could be a
five
uh i love that i love it um i
100 agree with daniel in terms of um
the things that he is fighting for i i
recognize i see myself in daniel and i
love that he is as vocal as he is
with that said um you know
one of the fun things in this show in
general is it you know and watching
characters is it it's not as fun if the
characters aren't flawed
right
so if we can see something noble about
the character but there's something also
flawed or misguided about how they're
doing it to me those are the are the
best characters right and those are the
characters i love to play so i love
playing daniel in that way where it's
like that there are times when you can
really see what he's talking about but
at all times you see he makes some
questionable decisions as he does make
some questionable decisions this season
i'm going to agree with you
i love talking to actors about the way
they get ready for like big moments so
i'm just curious say on a monday you're
going to have a really big scene that's
emotional or you know you really got to
give yourself to the moment
how early before that day are you
actually
really mentally getting ready and
breaking down what you want to do and
how much do you know what i mean can you
sort of take me through something like
that for me it's a process
it's a it's a it's a really really big
process you know um
and with this particular season uh
daniel was dealing with and talking some
things that were very um
close to my own heart center um you know
when he's talking about
uh
the systemic racism when he's talking
about um you know even the experience of
covid
um you know those things racial
injustice those things are really at my
center and so what happens is that i
begin to start to really try and digest
the information in terms of what is
daniel talking about and how am i
connected to that and reflected in that
and that takes a little bit of time so i
let that sit there and then i gotta also
do the you know all the mechanical work
was like i gotta get the lines memorized
and blah blah which takes a couple days
so it's all sort of like for me this
journey that then leads up to this
hopefully um release of uh whatever i've
been processing for the past few days or
weeks when we quote unquote shoot it
no that makes complete sense you get to
work with some uh really talented
directors this season and also in season
one um what do you enjoy the like i
think there's four directors in season
two can you talk about working with the
different directors if you don't mind
and maybe
you you know i don't want to say you
have a favorite but maybe you do
um you know uh it's it's it's
interesting right this is actually my
first series regular job so it's my
first time working within this format
right i'm uh usually you know tell the
story with one director um and so it's
been a a learning curve for me to you
know show up on set and then you gotta
get a quick sort of shorthand with okay
what's this person's perspective what
are they some people are more focused on
the camera some of them will those
people have more conversations with you
about your character and so i i wouldn't
say that there's um anyone that i'm like
this is my favorite but i there's things
that i like about
all of them and these sort of unique
ways that they approach things uh mimi
leader is uh so good i think that she's
an actor's uh director in the way that
she's able to have a nuanced
conversation with you about what your
character is is going through um we have
so many cool directors this season which
sometimes you know
i think the camera starts functioning in
these new and different ways with vic
mahoney um and so there's so many people
that and perspectives but that's the
thing it's like you got to figure out
what your conversation is with these
individual people
uh that is my time i'm just going to say
again congrats on a great season i wish
you nothing but the best and enjoy the
rest of your speed dating
thank you